you're listening to the dollop this is a
bi-weekly American history podcast now
each week I Dave Anthony read a story
from American history to my friend
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about yeah yeah
that's it
oh no no you hit your hand in my hand
just at the start the music no we do
this
oh that's before everything our podcast
this week is brought to you by Birdwell
Beach britches summer's here Gareth
you're close to it right
um we're almost summer it's summer
that's close well summers it's basically
summer where I am sure hot yeah you
ready for the beach the pool it doesn't
just have to be summer - its
unemployment season lake yeah I love a
lake yeah you love a lake you're
wondering what to wear this year in the
lake
sure forget about your flash-in-the-pan
trends and guesswork and get classic
surf style from Birdwell it'll a good
year after year you can just keep these
babies it never goes out of style
they're babies they're Bay Bay babies
they are one of California's original
surf shop board shorts sure I wear board
shorts when I go swimmin that's my part
of my jam yeah great
and uh Birdwell Beach nobody needs your
personal in 1961 surf mom Kerry Birdwell
man transformed her small Southern
California home into a sewing room and
store launching Birdwell in creating one
of California's first surf shops that's
pretty cool okay Birdwell britches is
pure Southern California and classic
surf style with 56 plus years behind
them Birdwell Beach britches are part of
the fabric of the Golden Age Southern
California surf culture just like the
Beach Boys hot rods and skateboarding
and dogs on skates on skateboard yeah
BRR birdies are guaranteed for life
whether it's Santa Santana factory every
pair of Birdwell Beach breeches are
individually inspected to ensure the
highest quality I'm doing the inspecting
of covered and that's when they're on
and
covered in a lifetime guarantee if a
seam stitch or grommet breaks you send
it back to the factory and they'll fix
it I don't even know what a grommet is
but you [ __ ] you get that new grommet
it's a green hobbit you get 10% off your
first Birdwell Beach breeches purchase
with lifetime guarantee and free
shipping over $99 go to Birdwell calm
and use discount code dollop a checkout
that's discount code do L owe P at
Birdwell dot-com pick up your first pair
of birdies and see why they've been an
American icon since 1961 they also have
awesome jackets which I'm totally into
which I might get one you're not gonna
get one but I'm like I know I'm sure
you're getting local for free and the
jackets would think it looks great on
you and yeah it was free they have like
a stripe down the front you can get
across the get across the front of chest
area sure and called the quote is
jam-packed
and we're back gosh thanks for coming
backing Drivetime dollop i say your uh
your guys and oh no there's like a big
big meeting of people it's been a while
is this the guy and you roll in and
you're just like you're just like nine
times a day you come you come late you
leave early nice like that move and then
after you roll out you're like hey that
guy said a bunch of [ __ ] and everyone's
there that's there's like no no he
didn't that guy didn't say that and
you're like well [ __ ] you I'm not gonna
play with you guys anymore and what if
there were reporters there are these are
children and what if the reporters were
there and the reporters were like hey he
said words but they literally didn't
make any sense and we're actually really
scared right now right say that happened
well if that happens to you I got a
really recommend the online therapy cuz
it's happened to a guy you know yeah
talk space talk space lets you message a
licensed therapist from anywhere at any
time all you need to do is get a
computer with an internet connection or
get the tox based mobile app you can
prove your mental health even if you've
had trouble making it in time in the
patent you this is for you the guy who's
traveling around if people are yelling
it you want twitter constantly and
you're yelling back he's a pal he's not
a pile I wouldn't say he's a pal okay
how's a bad word sure just a red-haired
beauty you know what I mean just a you
like out like a like if you saw if
someone took if someone took a like a
pile of just ground beef and they made
it into a elongated shape and then they
put hair on it I think that's what we're
talking about
nice hair no remember therapy isn't just
about venting your innermost thoughts
are digging into your childhood memories
it's also about practical everyday
strategies for stress management and for
living a happier life you can call up
and say hey maybe I shouldn't go outside
what if I live in the basement from now
on and let other
people do this you can do stuff like
that okay talk space platform has over
two thousand licensed therapists who are
experienced in addressing life
challenges we all face to match with a
perfect therapist for a fraction of the
price of traditional therapy go to talk
space.com slash dolloping use code dog
to you forty five dollars off your first
month and show your support for this
show
that's dollop sky.com slash dog it's
just a random i'm just coming up with
like a random person there there's yeah
actual guy yeah yeah like this guy if
he's totally like he's just some guy
that maybe maybe talk [ __ ] about the the
leader of canada canada has a walker
we're also barely we're also brought to
you by brooklyn and calm I know that you
I know you have a pretty sweet set of
sheep is that the sound you make when
you yeah I don't want to leave them mmm
they make a difference in how you sleep
you can hear Gareth right now get get
better sleep between your sweet sweet
sheets that's what I have to say
Brooklyn or calm linen calm the most
comfortable sheets no big markup right
there they feel like a like a princess
sheets but they're like Prince New
Artist yeah like the common man can get
them sure like you dirtbag that's really
what just happened you get what happened
you got crazy and then you started
saying what just happened when you did
it I have a pair of white Brooklyn and
sheets because I'm a normal human being
Gareth has a pair of gray ones yes he
likes to hide the stains
what's great doesn't hide stains really
yeah what if they're gray stains well
what do you just keep going to you eat
gray Brooke linen was founded in April
2014 by husband-and-wife team Vicki and
rich Fulop you loved the fool ops
philosophy was their philosophy the most
beautiful comfortable home essentials
without crazy prices no huge markups and
fees bedding is marked up as much as
300% most of the time not not Brooklyn
and they're the fastest growing bed
linen company in the world over 20,000
five-star reviews which you don't have
what's your deal right they were a
best-of online betting category by Good
Housekeeping which I went to that
ceremony housekeeping presented look I'm
saying it's luxury bedding it's under
priced get some Brooklyn and a sheets
are the best the most comfortable sheets
I've ever slept on Brooklyn calm has an
exclusive offer just for our listeners
of the dog get $20 off and free shipping
this $20 off and free shipping when you
use promo code the dollop at Brooklyn
and calm Brooklyn and is so confident
they offer a risk-free 60 night
satisfaction guarantee and a lifetime
warranty on all their sheets and
comforters the only way to get $20 off
and free shipping is to use promo code
the dollop at Brooklyn and calm that is
BR ook line-1 comm promo code the dollop
boom now let's talk about where you're
going great I'd love to David and
everybody else January June January
imagine June 21st through June 23rd I
will be at the stress factory in New
Jersey I'll be at a laughs comedy club
in Seattle June 29th and the 30th and
yeah and then there's other stuff coming
up there's other stuff coming up also
you are wearing a racist shirt no I used
to enjoy the NFL so Gareth yes we had to
cancel Boise but that's because job
stuff we are gonna reschedule it I know
people are mad some Chi some guy said
don't I heard you
this was something I couldn't I couldn't
change it so it's on me
Gareth can do whatever and employed
shaved piggy yeah but you can go find
out where we are gonna be at Dollar
podcast.com and all our tour info is
there click on the tour button and then
tour stuff will come up also you can get
our shirts from the James Fosdick site
on red RedBubble
all our all our official merch is there
if you see emerge any other site than
red bubbled that is not us and and those
are filthy lying dirty people and of
course I'm talking about teespring who
should be alright let's no more lawsuits
allegedly alleged legend allegedly
allegedly alright let's talk about that
really quick
yeah we did it we did it we did an
episode of the podcast we did it
wouldn't know it was about the veterans
stand thing but no dapple as they call
it the north dakota pipeline it was
about a gentleman mike woods and and he
he said hey we need to talk and i said i
don't want to talk and then and then he
said well that articles all lies and I'm
gonna sue them and I said are you
threatening legal action he said yes I'm
threatening legal action he would be
caught up in that suit and so I I pulled
it because I don't want a [ __ ] deal
basically yeah
I don't have time for losses yeah quite
simply yeah like it's there's certain
things you want you know from these
things you don't want your life but if
you want to go read about it it is on
high country news legend on you can
Google better and stand and it's not
allegedly you can go read about that
alleged
that's an article I'm just telling
people edge idli it's an article anyway
that's what happened there January 7th
1855 Jesus real weird I don't think you
do well with cameras filming because you
do this visual stuff which is just
terrible that's what I look like when
I'm sexing oh my god
what just happened rewind Charlie
Siringo Siringo so Ringo like a drummer
gets knighted SI RI ng Oh Ringo yeah
like that this formal right he was born
in Matagorda County Texas someone's
gonna be like it's made of Gorda yeah
it's on a strip and land on the Texas
Gulf Coast so it's like a mile show yeah
looks like a - it's like a little a
little sort of they call it a peninsula
oh my god but it's not it's not a I
don't think it's a peninsula is it not
there there it is how about that
so it's like um it's a little triple and
so he's born on that bad boy he looks
like a Barry Ireland right yeah I don't
know what a [ __ ] Barry Island is do
you yeah how do you not know what a
barrier I know exactly where Barry Allen
is what is it it's an island that serves
as a barrier for what for ships
no not for [ __ ] chips whales I don't
know I got halfway there his mother was
an Irish immigrant his dad was an
Italian immigrant oh that's easy
yeah his dad died when he was one sure
so we never got to do that accent yep
but we also would never laugh about a
child oh no because oh my goodness did
you imagine laughing about the child
from the 1880s whose father died when
he's won like every single person on the
dog Charlie started going to school when
he was four okay that's fine that it's
very not normal for that time oh the
Civil War kicked off when he was six and
then his teacher left to join the war
and that's the best news ever that he
didn't go school anymore fill it out
yeah school
four doesn't sound like they were rich
because Charlie war quote a long white
shirt made of a flower sack after some
of the big bugs had eaten the flower out
alrighty
they have that at the gap oh yeah they
do it's a matter of time okay so he's
just kind of in a bug eating sack he's
in a yeah he's an obsession it's been a
sack shirt devoured there's no more
flour in it he's just got a sweet sweet
snack on cool that's cool
how's yours keep going please his aunt
and uncle eventually sent clothes so
that was nice
that's cool yeah so then he had clothes
he hung out with his best friend Billy
quote our three favorite pastimes were
riding the milk calves [ __ ] hunting and
sailing play boats on the bay shore okay
yeah that's pretty normal childhood play
boats are just shooting raccoons milking
normal stuff he'd watch and imitate
local cowboys sometimes roping wild
steer so he started you know picking it
up a little bit as a yellow alert during
the war the Siringo family diet
consisted almost exclusively of fish
oysters corn bread and sweet potato oh
my god and diarrhea I mean yeah they
made their coffee from parched corn and
sweet potatoes oh my god which I like to
call not coffee corn fee we have corn
for here could I get some more potatoes
in my coffee no no we gotta eat the
potatoes later because we have ulster x'
and fish what about parched corn can I
get some more corn in my coffee wow you
can have a little more corn boy this is
a real pick-me-up hey are you up yet no
I'm still tired feel that cord pulse it
through yeah oh that corn in my vein oh
man I had too much corn there so it's
fighting all they were in the area they
were in there was fighting all around
him and dead men would just wash it but
shore on the beach the smell of this
family must which is fun I don't if you
ever experience men are just members
just floating up on the beach just dead
soldiers would just cruise up that's
cool just died
water floaters they call him great come
on the float
Charlie was invited to live on a ranch
to learn how to run cattle okay this was
a dream and he now considers considered
himself a quote full-fledged cowboy so
this is his dream so it's self realized
that he's living his dream young boys
living his dream but after two months on
the ranch
Charlie contracted typhoid fever and had
to go home just like a cowboy his mother
remarried a man named carrier hello I'm
the holder of things he said he had a
farm and lots of property of Michigan
and so they should go there he convinced
Charlie's mom to sell her house 60 head
of cattle and the the 175 acres of land
they owned
she didn't make much or you couldn't get
much money for stuffing because the war
is on and everything sure so she didn't
get a lot of money for it and then they
headed north
Charlie cried he was very sad okay to
leave his homestead as you would be I
think no Aaron have you ever left your
home when you were a boy trying to bring
you a buddy so he he's gonna miss his
cow brownie who Aaron is no Charlie okay
he was gonna miss us because I was
brownie brownie been around forever
yeah the family took a boat to st. Louis
up the river as I say on the boat there
was a bar a place to drink sure so
Charlie's new stepdad quote put in his
spare time drinking whiskey and gambling
nice and soon's had squandered every
cent received for the homestead and the
cattle no so I mean it had a the money
had a good run
yeah that's a bummer yeah so they get to
st. Louis they move it into an old
run-down building so that's not what
they were
this wasn't black thing this wasn't the
plan they're gonna go to Michigan yeah
yeah yeah where he city then he got them
so broke that he's like
we'll just live in this building Louis
what about here huh what about this
place that has no roof how much you
think we get for brownie so I guess a
sore subject
so his set his they get to st. Louis
they step down this isn't so bad huh
guys
stepdad finds a job shoveling coal for a
dollar a day hey I found a job that's
great for me oh good it's looking up
first he'd bring home a dollar every
night
each night come on with a brand new buck
then became 50 cents so they're jacking
my pay and then it was a quarter and
then he would come home just shit-faced
with a nickel well I did nothing but
drink again that is the day this isn't
it did you guys know that you can eat
call good have some coffee
finally one night he just didn't come
home hey my neighbor's fed the family
they were saying he didn't come home for
ages he was gone he was done he was done
okay interesting
that's that fun sure so Charlie then
earned money shoveling snow and sawing
wood around where he could okay and then
one day a letter came from their
stepfather with $10 inside okay from the
guy who bounced yeah okay so he's he's
showing that he's got his [ __ ] together
right he found a new job chopping wood
and he asked his wife to bring my
stepkids and join him in Lebanon
Illinois oh thank god yeah and she did
she was like okay well he's he's gonna
forms got together to get money you know
yeah he put ten dollars in some paper
right so he's he's good again he's got
so things went well huh for a while
uh-huh and then Charlie stepfather's
started spending less time working and
more time drinking okay so he's right
he's he's an alcoholic sharing all that
right and he's relapsing yeah so soon
Charlie had to take over the wood
chopping job so dad's drinking stepdads
drinking and Charlie's doing the work
sure making $8 a month to keep the
family alive Jesus quote I was working
out in the cold without gloves and only
half clothed so I assumed he was topless
working it's time to get that flower bag
I mean if we're talking
clothes I hope it's the top I hope it's
the bottom that's naked I always prefer
that look look stepdad started because
Nashville slept I started becoming mean
uh-huh so mean and worthless the
neighbors ran him out of the county okay
that's bad yeah
quote a crowd surrounded the house one
night took him out and preached him a
sermon then they gave him until morning
to either skip or be hung he didn't wait
till morning
ya know that was he was out okay well
good run the good dude no he had a good
you know you're good if the entire towns
like go yeah sounds like we're gonna
kill you so here's our deal we're gonna
kill you or you leave because you're too
awful you're terrible person also here's
a sermon
oh Christ is good Christie hey Christ
were you raised a religious man okay so
I can't get a bicycle hat bicycle Ana
don't do and I go there was your deal
Oh electronica electronica so what you
just know music from Sirius XM stations
I believe it to be electronica so
Charlie's now 13 years old okay his
mother and sister leave they go to find
work in st. Louis and they leave him
behind
he's 13 he can hey you can handle it now
for sure he's 13 alright so he comes
down with malaria cool yeah that's fun
adolescent yeah yeah yeah a lot of
adolescents get that but you can take
pills for that now sure that now yeah so
yeah he only had 90 cents because his
boss after his stepdad left he's like
well your stepdad owed $35 and that's
how much you had so that's cool so
Charlie then took off he's like I'm
gonna go to st. Louis and find my mom
okay which is easy to do st. Louis is
just a big city and all you have to do
is just go you're 13 you have 90 cents
go to st. Louis you figured out
out just walk in the st. Louis are you
worried about yeah you got 90 cents Dave
I think you're gonna be able to figure
it out yeah you got this
yep that's cool it's good that's
professional they teach that in radio
school so when he arrived he had naming
classes wherever you went to school yeah
when he arrived here he basically had no
money so he sold his Bible for 25 cents
to buy food oh my god right away did
that scary what why do you have that
yeah at that point that I mean that's
the equivalent of going to a Coinstar
yeah for sure that's a median yeah first
thing you do that was the original coin
stars you put your Bible in and there's
a cardboard it would come on how nice he
got a job as a bellboy and he worked for
a whole year
but then he got into a fight with a
bellboy and he left and and then he
decided go to New Orleans so he stowed
away on a ship got caught had to work
his way the whole way there yeah he got
injured cuz he was loading grain and it
fell on him sure he's having a good run
yeah so there he's broke and he's in New
Orleans now a little bit hurt and then
some weirdo just walks up to him on the
street hey I'm gonna picture a little
Pearlman if that's okay yeah that's fine
quote well-dressed old man about 50
years of age with an umbrella over his
head hello hello it's not raining
I predict rain let me freak he made
Charlie an offer to help his wife around
in the house for four dollars a month
and after four months he said he would
then buy Charlie's passage to Texas so
he'd buy him ice passage back home
okay passage meaning trip yeah right
okay it's a choice I call right I'll
help your old lady around for four
months sure weird guy who thinks it's
raining yeah so mr. mrs. Myers had a
very big home and no kids
this is Shady what this is just show you
if you don't have kids you go when you
find one on the street right this is how
you like get a bar is just how you get
like a body they treated Charlie like a
son mm-hmm
they enrolled him in public school okay
but then Charlie got into a fight and he
ran away okay on a fight school and he
just instead of going home he ran he ran
well so then they put him into a private
school
that's how yeah and then he got into a
fight with a bully sure and he stabbed
him in the leg
sure sure sure sure and then the bully
got up to run and and Charlie chased him
okay and then he stabbed him in the back
okay okay so just all right so are we do
we have all the stabbings yeah yeah okay
so that's classic 13 so he's got a leg
stabbing followed by the back stabber
yeah okay great okay uh-huh
so what's next boarding school or where
do we well Charlie thought he'd kill
them so he he jumped on a ship that was
going to st. Louis and stowed away okay
so now the big details coming he got the
[ __ ] out of there is what okay yeah so
is that the end of that again yeah that
was investors these people just put him
in two schools until he almost killed
the guy who thought he killed the guy
that he stowed away again yeah I mean
it's why you don't take in street
urchins sure so he he still couldn't
find his mom and st. Louis I think he
dodged a bullet with that cop yeah yeah
yeah this weird umbrella guy was
definitely gonna do something weird yeah
yeah you got a real get out he was gonna
end up bacon yeah something for sure
yeah hanging in the the basement or
whatever yeah cured meat no just some
sort of like you know nodded to the wall
sex slavery yeah yeah yeah I can't do it
anymore Charlie but I'm gonna watch you
and tell you what to do mmm give it to
the missus no could you hitting puberty
or you'll be bacon okay so he's in st.
Louis he looks for his mom I can't find
his mom and then he goes back Jesus to
the weird couple it's a no-no guys they
can house what do you got what because
they were feeding them and taking care
of him so he fatten him up like Hansel
and Gretel they they got him back into
the private school the private school
took him back what on what ground after
the stabbing did they remove his hands
no they were like oh he was probably
like I wants to have anybody anymore in
there nobody do it twice one guy I know
but maybe he deserved
i-i-i got away with two stabbings i mean
it so did he it's you're just a young
teen like it's just you know a crazy
time my voice is changing and I'm
stabbing more boy my body's going
through a whole bunch of different
changes here are my balls and I'm
stabbing people well um a couple things
have happened I'm getting uh nocturnal
emissions and I crave the taste of brain
sorry I'm one of these adolescents you
read about one day there was a fire near
the school and and Charlie was like can
I go look at the fire and the teacher
was like no and he's like well I'm going
to look at the fire and then and then
you know how you can bat that your
teachers of fire yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then he got there and he was like oh
[ __ ] I've I [ __ ] up I shouldn't go
back to school what so he hopped on a
steamship headed for Texas is he I mean
he's like Forrest Gump not he's not
great at facing problems yeah that's how
I feel right now he's a cutting runner
he's also a kid he's 15 or 16 yeah so he
he goes to Texas he gets a job working
as a cowboy on one of the biggest
ranches in Texas right so he's living
the dream he's back to living the dream
sure he he traveled the West drivin long
horn cattle Brandon unclaimed cattle
other Cowboys nicked him nicknamed him
dull knife cuz he had a knife that he
would use to kill rattlesnakes all the
time he'd throw it at him and stab him
then he cut their heads off why is it
dull knife cuz it's a dull person he
just cut it so much and he guys
sharpened it or whatever
maybe it's hard to cut they know about
the stabbings I don't know if they do I
don't know if he would bring that up to
people yeah probably not
hey guys you guys called me dull knifes
at avoiding the negging net in the leg
and then I stabbed him in the back and I
was like hey hey she'd leave anyway
that's my story no so sure I killed him
I left he could be dead and then I went
back to the couple I came back
I couldn't find my mom I mean I had 90
cents so after two years Charlie just
she was working and she decides to move
on get God and he went to settle up with
the old Irishman who kept the store
there so the guy would he would keep
their pay for when they were leaving
okay and then also they would buy stuff
at the store
sure his name is hunky-dory Brown I'm
sorry
hunky-dory brown his name was hunky-dory
brown it's a classic Irish name is he
Irish yep it was hunky-dory hunky-dory
yeah that's probably nickname so like
hunky-dory is like something Midwest
teachers say it's also a guy that's
insane
a lot of things are insane hunky-dory
yeah now are you I'm the original you
know when you feel like everything's
pretty good you just say me just think
all hunky-dory brown HDB yeah hunky-dory
I got it how are you I'm leaving
yeah well I'm monkey Dory okay and I'm
also doing hunky dory
so things that are lonely yeah yeah I'm
sure they are your name's terrible you
have a terrible name it's impossible I
know it's been an absolute curse I hope
you perish I am so oh you're suited whoo
hunky dory Brown Charlie Charlie
Wow hey so uh pocket so from the store
Charlie had earned a few hundred dollars
during the two years he had worked there
and hunky dory put it on the counter and
then told Charlie how much he owed the
store he took it all back and left
seventy-five cents what I mean so you
just bullies he's full of it well that
was just the classic that was the
classic move it still is a still move in
some places but they when you work on a
farm that's where they would do this you
also did eat a lot yeah you ate food so
that's gonna be a problem you ate a
hundred and eighty dollars worth of
beans
how much was my pay two hundred dollars
and then of course there's the
bean-eating fee waiting what that's $9
for eating the beans for eating the
beans plus four grand old plate usage
I'm just gonna
add those up oh boy what you're I mean
you're coming out pretty good you get 75
cents I worked here for seven years ah
yep no just think about that from a bean
standpoint a way I like to look at it as
you ate almost a billion beans that's
enough
beans don't think then you can't look at
something from a bean standpoint well
buddy I don't have time to talk about
bean POV with you here's your three
quarters take care hey there's no asides
in here sorry you're not allowed to
breathe the goddamn side on the door no
asides no shirts no shoes no service no
asides hey get out of here if you have
to decide get out of here if you're
having it aside get out google bean POV
and milf but buddy got it go when he was
18 Charlie and a friend started a
business skinning cattle finally he I
assume that the cattle were dead well
that's a hope after winter he made after
just one winner he made a hundred and
fourteen dollars okay so the most money
he's ever made in his entire life by far
[ __ ] rich he bought a saddle and
after learning he learned where his mom
was from a friend he sent her 25 bucks
he's like I'm fine
shit's goin crazy here hey and then he
bought a ship with a friend and named it
the Bloodhound
okay so we're [ __ ] rolling all right
he would then go down the coast Texas he
would buy melons sure and they would
sail upriver and he would sell them to
factory workers to eat on the lunch or
whatever hey guys come in a factory
eating like you want a melon right and
they'd be like yo won't you bet I won
Hey look there's that bloodhound boat
with all that smellin and when oyster
season would come he'd switch to Stalin
oysters instead of melons go upriver oh
that's just as refreshing thanks charlie
man that's quick Easter break in the hot
hot Sun we've been painting and fixing
all day those melon quenches your thirst
but so does that juice that sticks
around the shell of an oyster oh yeah
Mama's hydrated is there
a lot of factories like I know Ford one
of the oysters anymore they won't no
singer stopped allowing my colony
there's naming companies right guys
that's an equity oyster five don't exist
and then and they said then after that
he went but he got rid of the ship
anyone back to cowboying sure moving
herds getting cattle branding that kind
of stuff he drank got in fights just
lived a life lost a lot of money betting
an April charlie quote got shot through
the knee with one of those old-time
Dragoon pistols which carried a very
large ball okay so he's him immobilized
and he's like you know what I'm gonna
try I'm gonna try and go to school
against I can't do anything else okay
so he's basically an adult kind of
eighteen or something I'm sure he went
there for two weeks and got into a fight
with the teacher and left great okay
good so now can we officially say
schools not for him is it time to can we
well he doesn't have the best luck in
school well ya know people keep falling
into his knives now somehow word got to
his mom and he'd been shot and then she
came to help him but before she got
there he left he left and went to
Houston
obviously ships passing in the night
yeah so she stayed and waited for months
and with this I mean it just does show
you like the the so easy to contact
people yeah yeah I mean we're loving it
was selfish waiting months months in
huge don't he'll come back or no she's
she's in the pan Hitler Panhandle area
so she stays with friends who were named
Morris when where we are Morris hi we're
Morris we are all Morris hiya Morris
drink from the cup of Morris and become
one of us we are all Morris more drink
Charlie we are Morris all right so so he
comes back after a while I don't know
how long and then he decided his mom
decided build a house together they're
like let's build the house and we'll put
him on together bill the house sure so
they put together and they gave it to
mr. Morris who took a schooner to go up
to Indianola to buy
so he's heading upriver to buy wood sure
but then a hurricane came okay and this
is before they named him yeah yeah and
it hit while mr. Morris was going up the
river and the boat and everything on it
was gone including the money oh boy yeah
and mr. Morris he's all right but he
they lost the money I guess that was
maybe sitting on the top of the ship
under an anchor like you know if you
have a lot of money I'll just put an
anchor to put money down and then an
anchor on top yeah paperweight that's an
old sailor thing so the money's gone he
then he told his mom why I'm gonna go up
the trail meaning he's gonna go get
cowboy work and he said he'd be back by
fall and then she waited for four years
okay work it man just any way to give a
heads up no I mean it was hard a
possible way no I don't think so it's
not a snooze button what just laying the
years I think you can it's a different
time like some nowadays you'd be out and
you'd be like hey I'm gonna go out for a
couple hours and maybe out for four but
then but they don't was years you'd be
like I'm gonna be gone for the race
defense and then you're like oh it's
been eight years
hi I'm a man so he goes back to being
cowboy he's working on a ranch Billy the
Kid
well his gang show up one time kid the
kid was trying to unload stolen horses
okay the two guys got to know each other
a shooting contest Billy kid was faster
in 1881 Billy of the kids gang took
cattle from the ranch that Charlie was
working on so they came to sell horses
stolen horses and then they came back
later and stole cows from these guys or
cattle whatever and then and then they
drove him to New Mexico and then he was
having them butchered like you know take
taken care of for me turn him into meat
is what thank you yeah just because I'm
a vegetarian doesn't mean that I don't
understand when if you're gonna because
so meat comes from cows another animal I
guess I'm to get it you typically cut
the cow they're a little very clear
pieces basically understand and then
never not understand you can go to a
butcher and he will sell you parts or
something you will take them absolutely
yep you get that yes okay
charlie and a few others were sent to
get the get the cows try to get them
before they're butchered I understand if
not you can get you can get the what's
left of the because they're in peace I
understand how it works with a butcher I
get it okay just as I get it it's very
clear okay so they were told not to try
to capture Billy the Kid for the reward
money yeah Billy the cow until they had
the cattle so they're like you can get
to get the cattle first and then get
Billy right okay so Charlie found the
guy who was butchering the cow okay
right so this guys cutting up the guts
absolutely there's a ribeye we use a lot
of the parts yeah they do for sure yeah
yep okay yeah so and that was in Vegas
that guy was in Vegas of course and so
Billy was getting supplies and then he
heard that the other guys killed Billy
the Kid okay yeah Wow
so Charlie had to stay in New Mexico to
testify at the trial of the
slaughterhouse guy the butcher again
cuts up the cows yeah cuts me yes okay
so while he was there he got smallpox so
there was no doctor part of the delay
yeah yes part of it so there's no doctor
of course um so he has to right so while
he has smallpox yes to ride two hundred
miles Oh on a horse it's raining so he's
sleeping at night in the rain
covered in smallpox he and then he had
to hide his illness from people because
everybody saw him they would throw him
in a pest house which is where they die
in the West that's where they put people
had smallpox they'd throw you in a house
that's been a couple movies recently
anyway his quote face from nose to chin
being a solid scab and terribly swollen
mmm sexy I mean God it just does make
you like in in this day and age you are
so like just even neosporin just for the
drive just yeah just the ride there to
just be like ah oh the rain really dries
it out ow God
Charlie's asked that dad nobody make him
smile literally anyway you rented a room
put a handkerchief around his face state
I'm robbing banks good night wait as
well he and his mother he went back to
his mother they moved to Kansas so he
beat smallpox yeah okay they go to
Kansas together he's like let's move to
Kansas I'm tired of this [ __ ] yeah well
he wants to get to every state yeah yeah
and he got offered a job there in Kansas
so he took it
his mother's happy to go she's let's get
the [ __ ] out of here quote there is only
one thing she hated to leave behind
Charlie and that was her wood pile okay
she had spent two years lugging wood and
piling it up against her old shanty for
old age so that was like her she's a
wood hoarder
it was like her pension Oh interesting
why crazy sad an interesting Wow
yeah um it was a different time when he
was 29 Charlie met mammy Lloyd and I
quote I fell head-over-heels in love
with a pretty little fifteen year old
black I'd miss him I accidentally met
that this pretty normal bagman he's 29
so he's half of her age so when she was
when he was 14 she was zero which is
exciting so just three days after
meeting we were engaged and at the end
of the three days we were made one so
they got married
Oh like six days they got married yeah
that's pretty cool right that's good
that's that's good yeah three days later
he got he had to go off and drive cattle
back somewhere and he didn't come back
for six months so great that's a girl
meet a girl nine days later you're back
on your job yeah after a few days he
came back six months later after a few
days he was told he had to head out
again but he didn't want to leave his
new wife sure he's like I just we told
him and don't been able to do it for
three well he doesn't want to miss her
sixteenth yeah
so he swore off quote swore off cow
punch and he's like I'm not doing
anymore I'm not driving the cows Mami's
Macau now he ran a tobacco store sure
and also an ice cream and oyster parlour
what is going on with this man in
oysters I mean this is a perversion at
this point right man would you like some
oysters on your mint chip absolutely not
here we go just off the ice cream I've
been working for so long and I forget
how much the oysters just slide around
it goes heisters moister sprinkles oh
honey Nate you want to shell them do you
would you like your ice cream in a shell
an a/d Ram man likes oysters too much
and a deer and from that time Charlie
Siringo wants every cowpuncher Nestor
and [ __ ] in the United States to
know that he makes a specialty of fine
cigars and tobacco okay so he's not
covering a lot of demos different people
yeah
Manny made the newspaper herself quote
miss Charlie Siringo found $15 lying on
the sidewalk son Damon and as soon as
the owner was discovered returned it to
him honest little woman a man would have
kept it and played seven-up on that
stake for a week by the way we're not a
paper
we're just anecdotal typing imagine a
paper honey did you hear this story
about the woman who found $50 oh my god
if that was a man he would have kept it
that's what the paper saying ha ha ha I
love papers but they found the man who
dropped oh wow that's interesting whoa
hold on I didn't mean to distract it you
see this one story what's that there's a
man huh who has a frog oh my goodness
like a like a web like a faux hopping
frog yeah hopping frog oh my goodness
Wow we do live in fun times hold on a
minute hold on I've seen the craziest
thing I ever seen what's that this is a
story about a woman huh and she's got
flowers Oh oh my goodness huh I love the
news now you know what's interesting
think back in the 1600s when they didn't
have stories organized like this no what
did they do for fun well they just
stared at the wall oh man we're lucky to
live at such exciting time read me the
Frog story again all right now a man
after a couple of years Charlie thought
he was one hell of a businessman and too
big for a little town a man like him
belonged in Chicago sure he's not 31
okay he wrote his first book a Texas
cowboy or 15 years on the hurricane deck
of a Spanish Pony what yeah look that's
that's his book ah Texas cowboy 15 years
on the hurricane deck of a Spanish Pony
covers a little busy by chess a Siringo
I know it's chess lame isn't it name so
he's now 31 he's got his first book he's
killing it he goes to Chicago workers
there I'm not having a great time
they're trying to organize to get an
eight-hour workday the businessmen are
like oh you should have chains better
you should more churn you be more
stations like slavish and they also were
fighting for equal pay for woman women
you can imagine that's great that that
still hasn't happened so strikes were on
and others are being discussed like
around Chicago owners of factories
railroads mines services industries and
other businessman are not happy with
what's happening ok the McCormick Reaper
works made a 71 percent profit in 1884
and still wanted to cut worker pay okay
Wow yeah imagine imagine I can't imagine
imagine a guy having billions of dollars
now and not paying people enough money
to get off food stamps we live in fair
times now mezzos so they start hiring
scab strikes have there's gaps there's
fights with the scabs the police the
Pinkertons there's a rally at Haymarket
Square which was called the protest
police brutality which you're a big fan
of I'm
I think the cops should be able to do
whatever they want someone threw a
homemade bomb at some point I made that
exploded police were killed please shoot
people it's all [ __ ] mess okay
Charlie his wife and baby were rooming
with a family on nearby Harrison Avenue
quote we went to bed expecting a riot
before morning so we were not surprised
when we heard the explosion of the bomb
and soon after the shooting which
followed after the riot the city was all
excitement and I commenced to wish that
I were a detective so as to help ferret
out the thrower of the bomb and his
backers I'd like to ferret this man out
I'd like to get in on this did you say
ferret ferret I'd like to ferret them
out yeah mm that's a different thing you
don't want to throw them out where I
come I'm looking more for sex dungeon no
no sorry that's what I'm offering oh
that is the kind of ferret yes meet the
latex ferrets hmm so Charlie decided to
join the Pinkertons national Detective
Agency
oh wow okay which was headquartered in
Chicago he got a letter of introduction
from his bank sure mate Charlie the
letter quote gentlemen the bearer mr.
Charlie a Siringo we know to be a person
of good character and having been a
cowboy and he been brought up on the
plains his services and ability are
command abble to you the banks of this
yes the bank the bank wrote a letter of
recommendation okay
we had the bank I would love to go into
[ __ ] my bank now and just be like hey
can you guys I know you're a credit
union you know sad credit union but
listen I want to get a job at 7-eleven
we'd love to recommend you oh you can
we've always loved how you banked oh
yeah you bank really well thank you so
yeah we have no problem setting up a
general meeting over there
great yeah we'd love to get you in the
mix that we really would I mean we just
think that you're fantastic
you're a great bank you're a great guy
and we are the bank and we are great too
and you are great and we love having
your money here yes but we're rooting
for you that's awesome we're rooting for
this is awesome we're rooting for you
guys we love you
I can't I work here
yeah okay I yes yeah yeah yeah I mean
you seem unqualified but again we just
love you so much money we love you so
much
well you're not to touch it in any
personal capacity but we love it okay
okay that's a gun no it's in your face
uh-huh
okay this is a bad I'm doing a bad
interview yeah I just realized I
shouldn't do that great okay you're
still hired okay we're the bank we love
it I love money and we love that you
retracted when you pulled the gun out
that's great also I want to let a
recommendation absolutely come again
this suit great for sure I need the
tailor they just hey we don't have any
questions we're just a bank okay Charley
also use Pat Garrett the killer of Billy
the Kid as a reference okay
saying he had Pat said that Shelley had
assisted in getting Billy the Kid okay
why William Pinkerton then hired him
okay now William Pinkerton was his
nickname was big eye right
he is Allan Pinkertons son so he's not
he's not the guy who came up with the
Pinkertons he is the son of the guy who
invented the Pinkerton agency now that
now the original guy who invented the
pinger nage it was cool he was actually
he actually just solved crimes and he
wasn't a bad guy and then William took
over and William is what is known as a
piece of [ __ ] yeah so they but the
Pinkerton hired men of all ages colors
nationalities they didn't hire women
Allen had hired women but this guy
wouldn't hire women okay they even have
an african-american guy in the office
that they call black Jim sure which is
that's how you tell them apart from
other people you just yell up you only
have one black guy in the office I was
like you know yeah it's totally fun yeah
will do
yeah well budget let me call you back
Jim Jim will do but what good we can go
just to tell you apart really the only
way that's okay is if everybody else has
white buf okay so that guy over there
his name is Jim right uh-huh so we call
him Jim uh-huh
we call you black Oh can't we just call
him white Jim no why was Jim okay so the
agency is not really what Charlie was
expecting he found his line of work to
be filled with men quote devoid of moral
principle or character okay
he found the detectives were just
writing up fake reports that would
please clients
operative wrote quote blood-curdling
reports of things the anarchists were
doing to do we're going to do to society
and the money to class so he they were
just like making up stuff right that
they thought people would know people
would be doing and and they're
predicting yeah give him to the
businessman raking in the dough he was
immediately showing we never sleep he
was immediately shown how that's the
name that's the slogan of the Pinkerton
agency we never sleep whenever we're our
meth we're exhausted and God help us
take it to help League Pinkertons we're
listening from a lack of sleep in
Matthews Pickett ins there's bugs under
our skin him he was shown how to fill
out expense reports operatives were paid
eight dollars per day and all expenses
even laundry oh when he turned in his
first set of bills in superior gave him
back quote as he said the client was
wealthy and it was the custom of the
agency to allow their operatives to
overcharge so as to make extra money
this was how Pinkerton kept men employed
without paying a high salary wait
so explain this so Pickens not paying
very much money sure so they would just
submit fake expenses to clients right
and then that's how they were to get
their pay that's cool so Charlie did it
he doubled the expenses he was like okay
here he didn't like it he didn't feel
good about it but he didn't consider
exposing the Pinkerton agency he was
sure he wouldn't have been believed and
if he was believed the agency would set
him up to fall take a fall for a crime
right he's like I can't you know deal
with you these guys will [ __ ] me anyway
I have to steal I have to steal right
that's a problem and yeah he considered
quitting but justified staying by
convincing himself the agency would do
bad [ __ ] with or without him so he may
as well stay and do what good he could
yeah that's what's known as one of the
good guys
[ __ ] one of the good bad guys yeah I
mean if I wasn't here then he went to
Wall Street still be doing it yeah
Charlie was stationed in Denver that's
where he was sent sure one of his first
cases the Pinkertons were hired by a
wealthy banker who had stolen the bank's
money the bankers stole the bank's money
bank stills his own banks
okay and took off to Canada okay so the
Pinkertons were hired to make sure that
no one from the US came and kidnapped
him and brought him back to face justice
okay
and sure enough someone did come and
kidnap him and try and take him back to
the US but the Pinkertons got there in
time and saved him and brought him back
to Canada to live out his wonderful life
as a criminal on the run okay so it's a
good they're good people right as long
as they get paid yeah Charlie was the
only guys Superintendent Eames who's his
boss in Denver had not hand-picked so
he's picked all of his other detectives
except for Charlie got sent to him one
of his picks was quote a noted safe
blower
he told Charlie he had been part hey if
you give me the code I know how to make
it happy and what give me the code and
figured what's the combination of the
safe I don't know give me the combo I
give me the combo why take your pants
off oh hey I didn't this is that kind of
my goodness yeah hi how are you pants
are off pants are off pants are off hi
I'm nervous what happened no I'm gonna
suck huh no cowboy okay he's a capable
yo cowboy conversations over okay I died
below that yeah you didn't so two
Pinkerton detectives in Denver quote
kept trunks in the detectives room full
of stolen clothes jewelry and more one
of them went on to become the mayor of
Portland Oregon
sure trunk club normal stuff it was
common to bill up to four clients at a
time even though the clients so lawyer
that each operative was on their case
exclusively but his lawyer isn't it
Super Lawyer II 0.5 minutes on your car
I scan something that'll be $100 yeah
the Pinker said they did not get
involved in divorces but that was not
true so they would like out Lee
advertised and they didn't get involved
in divorces what we do but we never
sleep charlie and we're in Denver there
was one man who had an affair with a
woman and to keep it out of the papers
the man hired the Pinkertons to keep the
woman's husband quiet so the guy who
[ __ ] [ __ ] the wife how do they keep
the guy's husband cause that's how
they're gonna do this imitation yeah
right the Pinkertons plan was to meet
him in an alley and hit him with a pipe
okay so they're like really calculated
detectives and they really all right
boys we got to do this one right so we
took a lot of time we thought about this
a lot hey boss I throw the pipe alright
great so the four of us will go in the
alley and let's just beat him with the
pipe oh that's great
great great that's a call Thursday night
early night or a noisy night they
actually wanted Charlie to do it they
told Charlie to go hit the guy with a
pipe
really you're the best guy for the pipe
thing but he was like I'm not gonna do
that
okay cool someone else will do it then
so they ended up hiring an outside guy a
contractor situation are you doing I'm
the guy applied for money but then the
husband just beat the [ __ ] out of that
guy I saw it doesn't look bad down there
I wanted to go meet the guy I'm not good
with pipe so the guy took a pipe and
then beat me with the pipe so now
charlie is on the outs with
superintendent Eames like he's like why
didn't you go hit the guy with the pipe
you know a team player but he's needed
you to kill a guy with a pipe and you
back down so they told him he was
blacklisted from future murder cases
okay okay sure and he was like that's
totally cool right I'm fine with that a
little while later two detectives were
beating up a man in the office trying to
get him to confess to a crime that he
didn't commit and we know he didn't
commit them because the two detectives
had committed the crime interesting
dynamic for that I mean that it not
enough times are we seeing stuff like
that
well yeah you're trying to get the
confession to save your own ass it's
very it's a conflated yeah so Charlie
put a loaded pistol in one of the
detectives faces and told the innocent
guy to leave go after Superintendent
Eames told Charlie that he was going to
fire him but before it happened
Superintendent Eames and all the
detectives in the office were fired
because
William Pinkerton found out that Ames
was stealing per diems from the agency
on the side it's not enough to just run
clients in wine he's also stealing per
diems from the petty yeah I mean it's
like running paper yeah
we can't [ __ ] trust a criminal I know
it's weird Charlie ended up being the
only guy in the office who was not fired
so James McDowell and Jenna came now you
remember James McParland from doom or
the Molly Maguires episode you probably
don't nope so he is a guy who
infiltrated the Molly Maguires and took
them down during their strike okay right
yeah so he's a piece of [ __ ] right he
became the new supervisor and he sent
Charlie to Fairplay Colorado to help fix
an election he's a key to help fix an
election there's a wealthy man there who
wanted to become a senator okay so Herod
the Pinkertons and on an election day
Charlie and another detective were in
charge of a precinct okay and so they go
to saloons load up a wagon with dudes
take them to vote then drive them back
and give them two bucks okay and some
guys just did this all day long they
just repeat cool gang and make a nice
cash yeah yeah the Pinkertons did not
favor Republicans with Democrats just
whoever had money okay
nice yeah when he was in Denver charlie
voted eight times while he was dressed
up as a hobo that's fun for each vote he
got 25 cents from a democratic money guy
but then he had to give all the money to
the Pinkerton agency weird okay it's
just how you made a living man god it's
a good thing that we've secured our
elections like you don't complete that
doesn't happen
hey maybe cap wasn't has some issues no
what hey what just seems like there are
problems now not okay it just seems what
nothing okay it's like people take money
and then they do stuff yeah and it's
great be bad stuff because you need
money it's great but those are the
people you need to put money back into
the economy
duh what are you dumb yeah but if
they're what you're paying people people
will do bad things to get money yeah
sure but then they put that money back
into the economy
okay feel we're not and we're not
talking on the same sort of level okay
so people do people people need to make
money and and sometimes they can't make
money the way you want them to is they
have to do things that are wrong uh-huh
money yeah just to get by yeah yeah but
then they're putting that back in the
economy that's what makes the economy
good it's voodoo economics okay I get it
now yeah thank you for this talk yeah
yeah in 1887 Charley infiltrated a gang
three Pinkertons had previously tried
and they couldn't oh so he'd point break
them so Charlie faked that he had a
broken leg
ah my leg I should join up with you guys
and then they took him in ah man my legs
so jacked up and and and nursed him back
to health hey thanks for giving me all
those eggs classic bad guys yeah he
ended up becoming good what do you think
we should name him I actually already
have a name it's Charlie I want to name
him boo-boo
my name is Charlie na boo boo hey boo
boo I are you doing boo boo guys I'm
worried about boo boo I think he's sick
I laid with boo boo last night he was
weird we were talking about you know I
just had his head in my lap I was trying
to get him to purr I'm uncomfortable
guys I think we need to have boo boo
fixed I think he's I think he's horny
yeah he's in he keeps talking about
wanting to go out and talk to girls I
think we got to take off his stuff
what are you I don't want blue boo
growing up he's a [ __ ] man who's my
baby boo boo and I love him he's 35 he's
all mine and he's a baby boy all right
all right never mind let's we should
name him charlie
listen calm Charlie again because not as
catchy okay
boo boo you want to be named Charlie
anyway Charlie ended up boo boo becoming
friends of the guys and then having them
arrested but he felt that he felt bad
about sure he had him arrested he was
like all I feel bad it's hard going
undercover
yeah but then he pees Donnie Brasco yeah
but all their cases are dismissed so he
felt me felt better okay on next
investigated train robbery okay the
suspects were named Smith so he went and
got a job working for a farmer named
Smith who lived close by
that's good detective right they gotta
be related nobody has that name any
other Smith around here
is 850 what about that guy with a farm
he's a Smith let's go
alright quote farmer Smith had a pretty
black-eyed daughter and I made love to
her okay the girl showed me a letter
from her brothers in the letter they
stated they were going to a certain town
in Arizona soon oh and the 1880s
definition of made love was flirted the
definition of made love was flirted yeah
back then so they just were flirting he
flirted with it he did not have he did
not put his penis inside there was no
coitus I don't know why you got to be
like put her right in there David David
David David David David David Dave Dave
David Dave Dave Dave Dave David David
Charlie had the brothers arrested okay
and then the sheriff put Charlie in a
cell with the brothers to try to get a
confession okay
now the cell was still splattered with
blood because the last guy in there had
cut his throat
sure great I guess they didn't have
sponges or whatever back then no so they
just left the blood cool a turd about
right nice quote one of the Smiths had a
bullet wound through the head which gave
out quite an odor that uh on the
finishing touch of the already foul
smell in the air oh my god what what the
man is a smelly head hole he's got like
a rotting whale head I mean yeah it's
got a blow hole basically you had a
smelly uh head of all yeah okay hey man
you mind if we Corker owed and in my
head court come out yeah sorry you just
leaking volume that'll stink up oh it
stinks it right oh yeah to me it smells
good though you know well that's your
own thing yeah it's great to me no to
the rest of us it's a nightmare it's
good yeah look like bacon him a little
bit of broccoli you know like in bad
ways but it no it's worse yeah so uh so
after a few days he got a confession and
then so he wins that [ __ ] he's killing
it right killing it so next he heads to
Aspen
to go undercover as a miner which didn't
go well at first because he was teamed
up with another Pinkerton and that guy
was opening a box of blasting caps with
his knife and it exploded them okay and
he blew out both eyes and his hands off
hey has anyone seen my hands or my eyes
or my eyes the guy begged Charlie to
just shoot him in the head right there
cuz he didn't want to live like that but
charlie didn't and then and then the guy
was sent back east to live with his mom
oh my god oh oh this will be easy
so that's a great time to not have eyes
in hands 1890 poor guy honestly just
shoot him yeah I mean come on
so Charlie infiltrated gang of or
thieves found where they kept the or and
and had them all I said gang or thief
the gang we know so Undercovers becoming
his thing like he's clearly good at
going undercover right and then Charlie
was sent to Park County because the Lord
Mayor of London paid a hundred and
ninety thousand dollars in cash for the
mudsill silver mine and he thought it
might have been salted okay I'm gonna
explain that to you cos yeah so there's
tons of con men wherever those mines
there's [ __ ] loads of con men that's
how it works back then and they would
sell would I run this place they would
so worthless mines to rich guys okay
right okay so it's like storage yes it's
exactly like storage was not even close
there's some relative there's some like
related quality not even slightly for
sure not even in the tiniest I'll be
honest I haven't seen store so so
they're just standing there like boy
you're gonna love this mine right so
that here's how they'd sell it that a
common would take or from another mine
and scattered around the shitty oh look
at this yeah look at those silver
basically puking it son some guys would
take a shotgun load it with gull dust
and shoot the walls okay Wow Wow the
gold would embed itself into the rock
and then but then smart and so guys are
catching on to it so a smart buyer would
ask to see what was in the rocky but
like why don't you crack one of them
rocks open so then the con men would go
step further and find a crack and put
goal put dynamite into the gold and then
blow it up in there and then put gold in
the dynamite cap Oh
dynamite caps crack look at that gold
yeah geez
now it's salt the interior but some
smart buyers would bring a geologist so
there was also buy chloride of gold
which is liquid it was used as medicine
and passed through the body
so a guy could drink it and then piss a
crack piss in a crack in a mine and so
he'd piss in there and then gold would
go in the a guy this is to con people
guys would drink gold and then piss gold
you know what I'm talking about what
that's exactly what I'm talking you can
piss gold yeah we should do it we should
this weekend how long so Kanye West
pissed is gold
[Laughter]
God all I want to do is Pete gold now so
it tired I do that now yeah awesome bike
Laura I don't it's probably horrible for
you but you know well I mean entire
towns would be in on the scam as they'd
all make money from some rich guy buying
a mine
sure so Charlie eventually learned all
about the mine salting operation in this
town which helped the Lord Mayor recover
all his money okay he's [ __ ] good his
job right Charlie's great August 9 1889
mammy was diagnosed with pleurisy you
mean she can't make things sound
singular you can't
yeah
cats I love zoos that kind of stuff yeah
I ate all the dinners and I loves all
the world's okay we should take you to
the doctor because you're sounding to
the doctors mercy doctors
well there's one I have diseases okay I
need help okay with everything yes
all's it is this okay let's go doctors
okay
yes is so actually what it is is it's
like a an inflammation of the like a
layer you're drinking gold around your
lungs it's a it's a layer of infection
inflammation of the okay I can't I don't
know exactly what is but it's like a
layer right here long didn't get to
inflate about pissing gold you say
things twice so her father wanted her to
her to go back to Missouri where he
lived for an operation so Charlie sent
Annie
his wife and daughter off okay Charlie
was then assigned to learn who had blown
up to wealthy mine owners in Nevada
blown up that mine owners yeah they blew
up the people who owned the mine okay so
there's two mine owners and someone
rigged bombs under their beds during the
night oh wow so quote mister pelling in
his mattress went up through the roof I
love that story mister pelling in his
mattress and landed right side up with
care in the middle of the street oh he
was still wrapped in the quilts and
blankets hey what did I eat about the
shock put him out of business for a
while but otherwise he was not hurt okay
not so lucky was mr. Prince he was badly
used up but soon recovered he too was
blown out into the street but not on the
featherbed okay so one landed on his bed
one didn't right and that's and
anything's possible
he lived in a cartoon yeah sure yeah
yeah yeah
Charlie befriended the suspect then
talked him into heading out into the
country to prospect for gold together
okay so this guy he thinks did it and
he's like it's a friend zone he's like
what you see we go on a couple of
brothers got gold prospecting mission I
think that's great I like you I like you
let's go prospect that's prospecting me
and you
[Music]
there's Charlie Charlie in that guy
that's just Charlie I you know the other
guy might have been in that picture but
Moore's so so they're out there for nine
months fun and the guy finally spills it
he finally says what he did because he
thinks this guy's is broke so he got
arrested then word came he comes back he
finds out that mami's operation not
worked not like the pleurisy spread to
both lungs she's terminal it's in my
lungs so mammy and and little viola
their daughter returned from Missouri an
aunt was sent to care for her as well
okay and then she died in Charlie's arms
the ant man Bobo's lady died he begged
to take viola to take his daughter okay
and he was like why I know he there's no
I don't know what to do so he let the
aunt take his daughter sure no that's
love yeah absolutely he didn't know what
to do with her because he's like how do
I do this
how do you do daughter so he said
goodbye to his daughter and then miracle
of miracles he got smallpox again which
is impossible but he says he did okay
ASIMO so yeah you can't get smallpox
twice so either he didn't have it the
first time and he had something else
that was really bad or he got it this
time this time it sounds like he had
smallpox
okay perhaps it was a similar type virus
we I don't know but a medium it wasn't
good quote I had always heard that a
person couldn't take smallpox more than
once but I know better now he broke out
with sores head to foot and quote
swelled up like a Chicago aldermen so I
guess they're Globo Chicago politicians
are bloated okay a doctor came to check
on him and said he'd be dead in the
morning thanks for coming by enough
medical mumbo-jumbo doc what is it
you're dead you're gonna die you're
dying you're dead spike you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] is what are my
chances you fear [ __ ] you like your [ __ ]
there's no chance you're gone any
experimental procedures you ought to use
that man just
get out you smell it's awful think I'm
gonna be one of those ones that prayer
does it huh how are you even talking
it's whole horrible
it burns because I have the pox on my
towel and might I don't like you quote I
was swelled up like I got another round
of ice quote I was swelled up like a
barrel in every edge of my body even to
the soles of my feet and the inside of
my throat was covered with sores oh my
god I'm so long on my back these sores
have become calloused but on undertaking
to turn over onto the fresh sores who
has to try to get up I would scream with
pain and fall over on my back again
towards morning I could hardly get my
breath and I was suffering the torments
of Hell then for the first time I
realized the satisfaction of being
buried by loving hands and having
flowers strewn on our graves and when my
cry was over my teeth were set and they
made up my mind not to die I was
determined to fight off death with all
the energy left in me Wow and when the
doctor came the next morning he was
still alive
Jesus doctors we already booked the bed
he'd beaten the fever and he was safe
Wow and then he decided he liked New
Mexico he's like I actually like this
place sure I'll take smallpox to
appreciate yeah it really does they said
that's their slogan yeah and so this is
where he said he wanted to build a home
and in 1891 Charley was assigned to go
undercover as a miner in Coeur d'Alene
which is in Idaho it's like the top part
of Idaho
it's beautiful oh where they keep the
white supremacist trouble with the my
right yeah okay there's a lot about
their job what the miners was brewing up
there right this is where my family is
at that time okay and and the owners
mine owners wanted to get a spy inside
the Union they're having trouble Charley
refused because his quote sympathy was
with the labor organizations as against
capital sure so he's one of these commie
times weirdo his boss came back a month
later and said pretty please and I was
like okay okay I mean how many more I
was gonna guy hair right the Coeur
d'Alene area had a few mining camps the
toughest one so the toughest place is
gem which is a city now ghost town up
there
that is gem Idaho that's where Charlie
went about 500 miners working three
mines only the mine superintendent knew
who Charlie was everyone else did not
know okay he joined the gem miners Union
and soon was elected recording secretary
of the Union because who wants that
[ __ ] job recording second writing
everything I thought he made the album
for the group and then he got himself
fired from the mine okay on purpose so
he could have more time for spying and
he just told all the other Union guys
that he had a rich dad a cent of money
okay do you see any problem with that
plan well he's trying to infiltrate well
if you're a miner why would you have a
rich dad who would send you money why
are you there in the [ __ ] first place
I mean yeah in my head it was like he
was trying it like he was like a rich
boy it was like well it didn't take it
turns out my hands don't like a callus
anyway I figure I'll just sit here and
buy the boys beer when they come over so
he joins us Union group he joins these
dudes who were bad who were bad Union
guys I guess that's what he says okay
anyway here's some here's some I know
there's some miners that's look like so
they so they were threatening men who
wouldn't join the Union right okay it if
it didn't work
threatening them they would form a mob
to scare the [ __ ] out of this guy and
sometimes a dozen scabs their wives and
kids would be driven out all at once of
the town okay and they would shoot guns
over their head as they left nice call
making a point right yeah we still make
that point Charlie found the leaders of
the Coeur d'Alene teams to be quote a
vicious heartless gang of anarchists
okay
this caused Charlie to change his mind
about miners unions okay
he regularly sent reports to the
Pinkerton agency Charlie also bought a
building in town and started a small
store where they Miss Kate Shipley who
had a five-year-old boy Charlie lived in
the room upstairs she lived in the room
downstairs
hey I'm just saying so late oh girl
things happen
he built the fence out back move built
the tall fence out back and left one
board loose just in case there was
trouble nice and in the spring of 1892 a
strike was declared throughout the
region
the miner and the mines were closed for
business Charlie learned the ins had
picked the worst men in the unions to
scare the [ __ ] out of the scabs scabs
rarely then would venture away from the
mine that's where they lived their
quarters are at the mine they stay at
the mine but when they did they were
basically beating the [ __ ] out of almost
to death okay
so Charlie recorded everything discussed
in the union meetings and some members
began to suspect Charlie might be a
Pinkerton no one warned him to leave
town or he'd be killed so Charlie didn't
leave he kept his gun in his bowie knife
clothes he's got that fence loop
he's got the fence never get about and
do not forget about the fence the best
thing meant is a hole in the fence fence
plan yeah that's the whole time he's
thinking I got this against gate a fence
whole gate gate he learned that too
scabs at the gem mine were going to be
murdered and he went to warn them so
there it is saloon in the town or
something he goes to warn them but then
he gets out is you from the future
mister he sees a big crowd is formed in
the street okay and old shoemaker
Robinson told them to get out quick okay
but the crowd saw Charlie had circled
around him okay and then he had a he
pulled out his gun and he slowly backed
across the street pointing his gun at
everybody and then he went into the
building that he lives in hey but he
still wanted to warn the to scab guys so
he climbed he goes up to his room and
they climbed down an emergency ladder
he kept out back and then he went
through his loose fence board nice it
does work plants if I can come together
it's like listening to an episode of
Miami Vice or something absolutely yeah
and he crawled through a swamp to the
river and then he crawled on his stomach
past two guards on the bridge and he
finally warned the superintendent and
then they sent men down to get this gabs
but they had already had
she beat Adam they're still alive wow
that's called a day that's a fun story I
bet he's thought he did all that quote
one of them was beaten almost into a
jelly oh my god what the what just there
are some times where things are set on
this podcast that I just cannot tell you
can't jelly yeah yeah if you had any
bread it's fine but without bread it's
weird you know what I mean you guys here
dan got made into a jam
Oh toast is there toast look at the
preserves those are those are pieces of
bone oh that's Bob yeah Wow delicious
well Bob sort of took into a more humus
form oh yeah look at that
hi oh hey that was making from under my
throat yeah he was beating almost into a
jelly his jaw and several ribs being
broken in fact he lost all resemblance
to a human being
oh my god except in shape oh my god Dave
his face was one massive bruised and
bloody flesh
Charlie stayed in the store that night
obviously I wouldn't leave my place at
that point either no mrs. Shipley
learned the mob was going to start it up
again before daylight there were now
over a thousand Union men who had come
from all over the district and they were
in town and they were ready to write 300
armed guards and non-union miners were
at the mines Charley was then positively
ID'd by Black Jack Griffith he was one
of the guys who had blown up the two
mine owners while they were sleeping on
that mattress he IDs that guy's a
Pinkerton so then 50 men waited outside
the store with rifles it's jelly time
yeah it's Charlie went to miss Shipley's
room and sawed a hole in the floor I
mean these real old-timey he is not a
cartoon we established that he is an
animator he's definitely not okay he's
definitely make sure he's definitely
real he's a real person although there's
a one coming up later he he has a hole
and he takes it off a tree and he throws
it on the ground and
that's that's an elitist sound Buster
Keaton it's an old escape plan I left a
hole in the fence so he said goodbye to
miss Shipley and then he dropped out
drop down out of the out of the room and
she pulled the trunk over the hole and
then what so then the miners blew up the
Frisco mill right there sure and they
headed down to burn their plan was to
burn Charlie at the stake to make an
example of Pinkertons right great he was
still hiding under the store okay
I heard the mob rush in oh my god and
then he crawled out and under the wooden
sidewalks
he's just inglorious basterds like he's
living that existence so he he just
crawls under the wooden sidewalks all
the way to the edge of the town what is
that what nobody else is thinking that
and then he got in like I know what it's
called like a water flute or shoot or
whatever it is or the water side no
that's not a water slide please it's
like a water slide it's a water slide
he's ever seen the Apple Dumpling first
water slide have you seen the Apple
Dumpling gang I'm gonna go and so he's
in that and he goes down that and guys
shoot at him did they get a picture of
his face when he was at the end I think
you buy at the shop and then he gets out
and he runs across a 200 yards of open
land to the gem mine
okay tells those guys what's going on
okay and they were and the it turns out
that he had found out that the miners
were gonna take a train car and roll it
from up above the mine down to the mine
to try to blow it up Wow and then he
somehow made a thing that would direct
it in another way so he spoiled that
plan like Superman he flew around the
earth to reverse and then and then they
yeah they he flew back yeah and then
they really want to kill him so him him
and another guy they also want to kill
ran up the hill and ran away and went to
Spokane Washington okay that's a good
story
yeah no it's normal yeah it's what it
was like back then yeah so then the
government came in all coeur d'alene was
put under martial law
Charlie was appointed a you
deputy marshal and he supervised
soldiers on a roundup of Union men and
they put 300 young men in a temporary
wooden prison
Charlie became a star witness against
all the leaders the trial lasted for
weeks 18 were convicted but he regretted
working against some because he was like
I like I still like Union guys okay but
he never forgave the union's for what
happened in Idaho Charlie also did not
believe in their cause now here's the
deal the miners were demanding shorter
hours and that everyone received three
hundred three hundred three dollars and
fifty cents a day okay everyone quote
the same wages as skilled miners so he
was basically like that's [ __ ] up they
want guys who aren't skilled miners to
also make the same amount of money as
them right he wants a scale he wants a
scale and the miners are like everyone
should get paid for their [ __ ] time
time is money why can't everybody have
the same value for their time and and
Charlie was like no you have a skill you
should get paid more okay [ __ ]
animals
Charlie's world is worse so he ended up
afterwards going to Denver he had a
bunch of money from the job had been a
year over a year so had a bunch of money
saved up and then miss sharp Lange wrote
and said that they burned down the store
oh that's cool so he was out three grand
at 38 he met a new lady in 1893 Lilly
Lilly Thomas she's 21 okay so he's
moving up yeah no he's a legal age they
married quickly he had a son three years
later and what's quickly for him in an
hour I'm maybe five days okay and then
the marriage was over as soon as the kid
was born sure Charlie was then offered a
Supervisor position by the Pinkerton
agency but he turned it down
quote I knew my conscious would not
allow me to act as the superintendent of
the agency in a big city where so much
dirty would be expected of me yet he
works for them and does [ __ ] dirty
he's all good we start saying dirty like
that he's all [ __ ] dirty stop it bro
no no there's so much dirt happening now
here's a picture of a blown-up mine if
you want to see that I'm sure
it's just what I'd imagine right so
that's a lot of retirement would so the
Colorado
that's pension kind Colorado my strikes
happen which we've talked about in
another episode of the dollar yeah yeah
unlike the Coeur d'Alene situation
Charlie didn't feel good about
infiltrating striking coal miners to
inform them on them quote I considered
their cause a just one as men who take
their lives into their own hands every
time they enter a coma and should be
paid double the money which they
received therefore I hated to report
their threats against the greedy
corporation which treated them as slaves
but he did nice I mean is he just
fooling himself yeah I think he's just
[ __ ] it just says that he's literally
he's the guy throughout history who like
takes the orders at my lai and kills the
Vietnamese right I feel bad
terrible my heart goes out to you now
let me get your hearts out of you in
that you know for Charlie bought a
Russian Wolfhound puppy he named it
Jimmy longlegs
hi you're a dog and I'm gonna call you
Jimmy Louis that's not it but that's
what they look like
yeah well cuz like a lassie hot dog foot
so it has long legs you can see how it
got the name yeah but after the dog more
like hairy hump less camel after the dog
ate a whole duck in front of him he
changed his name to eat him up Jake oh
my god wait so I went from Long Legs
Jimmy and then the dog ate a whole duck
and he became eat him up Jake yeah okay
hey that long Jimmy no I changed his
name cuz he ate a whole duck eat him up
Jake Charlie's daughter
viola graduated from college and spent
two weeks at Charlie's ranch getting to
know each other yeah yeah
yeah blow them up Jake Charlie's mom was
living in Kansas and at the 1904 old
settlers meeting in Caldwell Kansas she
got the prize for the quote lady having
been a widow greatest number of years
boy that's a it's just nice to be
nominated when I went to Bridget Siringo
her 49 years of widowhood earned her
$5.00 that's awesome
isn't that great what an honor I mean
this story has a happy ending
yeah yeah that's good in 1906 Charlie
went back to coeur d'alene some of the
union leaders he had betrayed her on
trial for the murder of the ex governor
of Ohio the Pinkertons were involved in
catching the men and guarding duties
during the trial all the men were
acquitted though Charlie thought the
agency didn't do as much as they could
have to win the case quote the
Pinkertons just grafted the state of
Ohio out of thousands of dollars by
putting extra operatives to work on the
case where there was none
no need that the [ __ ] Pinkertons are
the first awful American corporation
it's not insane
it's great just nice to be immersed yeah
[ __ ] grafting and taking money
everywhere
after the trial Charley resigned for the
Pinkerton agency he went to live at his
ranch in Santa Fe New Mexico he was done
but he had what he called a dark blot on
his conscience
from working against the coal miners in
Colorado okay not against the other guys
put the coal miners sure yeah quote
these men and their families are treated
as slaves by the greedy corporations who
owned the mines I know it to be a fact
that the Colorado fuel and iron company
and the victor fuel company of Colorado
virtually owned the sheriff's and other
court officials in the southern part of
the state so I guess I like this kind of
guy that's the Colorado feel an iron
company but this clenches yeah so he now
he feels bad because he's looking his
life and he's like oh I [ __ ] over tons
of working men right so I don't yeah
well yeah that's fight you're allowed to
that's that's the easy way to do it yeah
right right yeah the hard way bad
conscience the hard way is to go find
another job and not do that yeah
of fuel of Colorado fuel and iron quote
I became personally acquainted with the
president of the company mr. Keebler and
he told me I actually have a group of
elves that but I don't wanna I'm
starting a couple businesses but this is
what I'm focused on now
but I have moping another Factory in a
tree let's say wait you're robbing a
factory in a tree it doesn't sound like
the space would accommodate but believe
me it's plenty I'm not sure I understand
anything I probably have said too much
but I'm excited
elves mmm do you like biscuits with
fudge mr. Keebler told me that the
secret of his company is else in downing
the union's was the mixing of
nationalities in the coal camps hello
that the unions cannot hold the peoples
from different countries together into a
solid mass right yeah it is that is true
you know that thing when people say
they're evil they're doing this thing on
purpose it's a master plan it's like
that's actually what you're the people
who say it charlie married again in 1907
and divorced again in 1909 okay I just
left I just went through that one faster
sure yeah his mom came to live with him
but then she died 1911 in 1913 at 58
years old Charlie reunited with Helen
Partain she was the widow of a rancher
he had worked for 40 years before okay
they were married in Hot Springs
Arkansas and the wedding got a
front-page headline quote old couple is
married here great well I want to read
more that's for sure read more old
couple married here so eat him up Jake
devours again
hello know the facts with a silver
pistol the article said quote the groom
led a life of adventure and the bride is
pretty for one of 51 years of age now
it's crazy when people say that there's
a double standard because I think that's
pretty clear
that everybody's held to the you know
everybody you know you're just judging
people in the same piece had a great
life and my god her face isn't horrible
well this man's had quite an adventurous
life and you gotta see the legs on the
Dame they moved to Santa Fe the marriage
lasted less than a year nice to clearest
Rhonda man who invented divorce yeah
to clear his conscience Charlie started
writing books again okay
he wrote how to marry eight women quick
he wrote Pinkertons detective cowboy
which there we go yeah it's about his
time of the agency the Pinkertons sued
him to stop the publication and tied him
up in court for two years he was
eventually able to publish it but he had
to change the name and the title became
you can see the title down there the
cowboy detective a true story of
twenty-two years with a world-famous
detective agency giving the inside facts
of the bloody coeur d'alene labor riots
and the many ups and downs of the author
throughout the United States Alaska
British Columbian Old Mexico also
exciting scenes among the moonshiners of
Kentucky in Virginia anyway that's the
title it's a working job no that's a
little short yeah it is I'm just gonna
be on it yeah it's not enough it's too
short
okay what about mayor also married a
bunch I think you want even more dog
owner how about this
the dog owner dard wheat dog formerly
long leg Jerry need him up Jake duck
duck eater good dog had smallpox in my
throat one time hard to swallow double
double small pot guy my wife died of
making things plural right anyway that's
the title alright great things good um
the legal fight almost bankrupted him
over the book but he was not deterred he
wrote another book to evil isms
Pinkerton ISM and anarchism by a cowboy
detective who knows
yeah the cowboy detective it's alright
oh there's more sorry - evil isms
Pinkerton ISM and anarchism by a cowboy
detective who knows as he spent 22 years
of the inner circle of Pinkertons
national detective agency it's up with
the titles honestly I'm just unable to
you want to get you want to I catch
everyone I catch her yeah I know what's
inside yeah right you want to get them
once they read the cover they'll have
read the first chapter like these are
some of these are shorter than a trailer
to a movie but for sure but it's the
same sort of idea right okay great
Pinkerton sued him about this book the
second book and one so Charlie was
forced to turn over all copies but then
he just printed it himself
sure bigger didn't tried to steal or buy
up all the copies of the book or destroy
them the agency tried to have Charlie
prosecuted for libel but the New Mexico
governor denied his extradition okay
from 1916 to 1918 Charlie worked as a
ranger for New Mexico helping catch
cattle rustlers he wrote and published
more books some autobiographical one
about Billy the Kid he became known as
an author right he's like the first
western author nice Pinkerton agency
kept intimidating publishers to halt his
publications so he didn't make very much
money at some point he wrote a fan
letter to actor William Hart he was a
big fan it was a big silent movie guy he
was like the western star of silent
movies okay Hart responded as he'd heard
of Charlie through his writings and the
two men became friends and in 1922
Charlie came down with chronic
bronchitis health and financial problems
forced him to leave Santa Fe okay he
moved to San Diego to live with his
daughter and now 14 year-old
granddaughter and they nursed him back
to health and then he moved to Los
Angeles where William Hart became an
actor yep no Cal work is it consulted on
at least one Western movie and gave him
bit parts in movies to earn Wow Wow he
hung out in a tavern called the watering
hole which was a favorite hangout for
actors Charlie died at his son Leroy's
house and Altadena California on October
18th 1928 which is right next to where
anything
so are you him I'm him this that's the
end of the story I know that Charlie
Siringo
I knew it and I've been infiltrating the
dollop for over four years
your Pinkerton yeah and I've been
sending reports to Pinkerton about me
and you're a [ __ ] socialist what call
me know
piece of [ __ ] uh-huh and I love money
I love money this actually does sound
like you that's how you soon oh look
there's another picture of him with the
dog Oh eat him up Jake eat him up Jake
eat him up Jake Wow all right well we
have ourselves it was just uh the depth
first Donnie Brasco yeah I know I mean
but I mean I learned a lot about storage
or these [ __ ] people who go through
who are in history who do evil deeds and
then feel bad about it and write a book
and go [ __ ] themselves
don't do the [ __ ] evil deed we don't
even get books anymore yeah you know
we're we're past the apology part yeah
but yeah I think that yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] know that you feel bad that you
did that you didn't have a moral compass
in the moment you know
yeah and the Pinkertons were animals no
no oh oh man II I'm not sure about
biology hey that's okay this is gone on
long enough
yeah I guess so okay yeah anything else
to say anyway check out check out dollop
podcast
oh wait calm oh yeah go lawyers you know
we're gonna be in Denver and Salt Lake
all the cities that Charlie law will be
there in July yeah and then after that
we're in Minneapolis Wow and imagine a
CVM in Nashville Wow
there's a couple more that are gonna be
in those yeah scheduled Boston's
happening you see not ago I Chicago -
yeah thanks Tigers badass
yeah yeah yeah I'm so there's not gonna
be the second chest because a lot of
people like taking show but the that
that killed me last tour so that's one
show and I wanted to do three so Dave's
been a real jerk about it yeah cuz
Gareth doesn't do anything that's not
true
someone has to get fries for the green
okay Turkey
all right thanks everybody we'll see you
as you already next time soon